j'accueille kenza braga et olivia cattan
soir
fars alors qu'ils avaient été découverte
par le grand public lors de votre
participation à loft story
depuis vous êtes devenu journaliste à
radio orient à respect mag et à le mouv
voilà vous ai publié trois livres et
vous est la marraine de ni [ __ ] ni
soumises
voilà qui ment olivia est journaliste à
tribune juive vous collaborez également
à france soir et à paris match et toutes
les deux ensemble ou publié chez ram
c'est un livre qui s'appelle deux femmes
en colère avec une préface de marek
halter voilà alors c'est un coup de
gueule contre les préjugés à l'encontre
des juifs et des musulmans mais aussi
contre vos propres communautés dont les
religions n'ont pas encore dit vous
intégrez les apports de la modernité
pour les femmes voilà alors que nous
avons raconté dans le bouquin à une
anecdote qui explique vos motivations
en avril 2004 vous recevrez sur radio
orient vous travaillez dans une émission
que je vais être 100% femme emilie
frèche pour un roman qui s'appelle le
sourire de l'ange où il est question de
l'amour impossible entre deux
adolescents un juif il n'use ullmann et
les réactions des auditeurs vous choque
d'où l'idée de ce livre oui c'est vrai
qu'à un moment donné où l'ambiance s'est
transformée assez rapidement disons que
la religion a pris pas sur l'amour
puisqu'en fait la thématique essentielle
de l'émission c'était l'amour at il
droit de cité et c'est vrai qu'on se
demandait justement si un homme et une
femme de confession différente ou
d'univers complètement différent est ce
qu'ils avaient la possibilité de vivre
leur amour au ce land d'un quartier
sensible et s qui le visait finalement
de la même façon s'il était tout
simplement au centre-ville
et c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des réactions
très très très agressive d'abord vittavi
d'emilie frêche divise à vis de mon
invitée qui était sur le plateau et des
avis de moi aussi parce que je suis très
vite
je suis très vite passé pour les
éditeurs qui m'écoutait tous les jours
enfin pas pour tout le monde mais pour
en tout cas quelques-uns de mes
auditeurs pour un peu la traître des
services parce que j'ai évoqué une
thématique sur un amour impossible entre
une musulmane et un juif et en fait je
pense que j'ai
je pense qu'on a le droit dans ce pays
d'évoquer ce genre de sujet et
heureusement
et je pense que c'est possible et c'est
vrai que le fait de dire que c'est
possible a choqué pas mal d'auditeurs
ouais je vais faire ce bouquin oui c'est
vrai que disons que on est passé très
très vite à une ambiance assez assez
lourde
d'abord parce qu'on était tous choqués
par ce manque de tolérance et puis ce
manque de dialogue entre les gens il ya
eu des réactions vraiment raciste on
peut le dire raciste et antisémite à
l'égard de mon invitée et donc gelé
défendu j'ai pris son gg prison son côté
c'est normal c'était la moindre des
choses que je pouvais faire
et puis clairement je suis pas chez moi
pour les traîtres des services et l
malheureusement pour la jupe des
services bien alors donc c'est alain
soral qui vous a présenté l'une à
l'autre et donc vous commencé dans le
bouquin par parler de vos racines vous
olivia vous êtes juif pieds noirs
d'algérie d'alger en 1962 votre famille
est venue ans en métropole vous naissez
en 67 et vos parents sont très déçus de
ne pas avoir deux garçons surtout mon
père qui s'attendait à avoir un petit
garçon donc c'est vrai que ça soit sur
les musulmans chez les juifs
la naissance d'un petit garçon c'est
beaucoup mieux qu'une petite fille dont
il y avait pas de youyous de
réjouissance à tous à tout cette fête
organisée pour pour la circoncision et
c'est donc c'est vrai qu'à une petite
déception mais ils se sont habitués
alors à l'école vous découvrez le
racisme en fait l'antisémitisme vous
fait traiter de sale juive par départ
des jeunes filles catholiques à 6 ans à
six mois je peux pas dire que j'ai vécu
maman l'antisémitisme de la part des
musulmans moi ça a été vraiment bon
c'était une autre époque aussi j'ai
quand même trente huit ans maintenant
donc c'était vraiment avec les
catholiques avec l'extrême droite aussi
avec lesquels on se bagarrait quand on
sortait du
ouais parce qu'ils nous attendent et
devant donc c'était c'était encore un
autre anti sémitisme circle et vous
reprocher d'avoir tué jésus quoi voilà
donc les histoires alors en 4e 22 lors
de l'attentât de la rue marbeuf duo
terroriste carlos
votre frère qui était à l'école à côté
de la rue marbeuf est très choqué par sa
les vitres sont brisées par dans la rue
ils errent dans les rues pendant
quelques quelques heures où ils ont
laissé en fait ils en feront sortir dès
qu'il ya eu l'explosion et c'est donc
c'est vrai que depuis ce moment là sa
vie a changé il est devenu handicapé
mais va garder des séquelles
oui des grosses séquelles de grosses
séquelles et quand vous avez la sorbonne
vous vous battez quand on insulte israël
moi j'étais un peu la jupe de service il
fallait que j'ai absolument un avis sur
israël donc partir du moment où vous
êtes juif il faut vous preniez fait et
cause pour une nuit voilà pour soi pour
israël soit pour pour la cause
palestinienne mais il faut donner votre
avis impérativement donc c'est ça qui me
moi qui me choquait parce que je me
sentais française j'étais française
avant tout j'étais juif bien sûr c'est
ma confession et je suis très fier aussi
comme elle de mes origines mais pour moi
la française d'abord avant de tuer
maintenant des huit dont on me prenait
toujours un parti et dis moi qu'est ce
que tu penses
et ça c'est vrai clip pour moi ça m'a
choqué ça m'a marqué parce que je me
suis sentie différente et vous aviez
aussi des problèmes avec les ashkénazes
et séfarades sont des arabes
ben ouais on nous appelle les juifs
arabes on est on est plus proche c'est
d'aider les arabes nos traditions nos
coutumes pour les mariages pour une
et pour plein de choses puisque avec les
ashkénazes est vrai voilà le cvo hasina
vous vous étiez à bagdad
votre famille j'ai très déçu d'avoir un
garçon aussi
oui surtout surtout ma grand mère ouais
tout à fait d'ailleurs ma mère a pas
être du tout eu le droit aux youyous
habituel injustement qu'on donne un
garçon et c'est vrai que dès le départ
ma grand mère avait l'impression que le
ciel lui est tombé sur la tête alors
éducation assez stricte
mais heureusement votre père vient
terminer ses études de médecine en
france à nancy à lyon donc là dessus une
espèce de bouffée d'air frais et au
retour en irak s'étaient élevées dans
une grande animosité contre les juifs
oui c'est vrai dans les manuels
scolaires
il nous était régulièrement en tout cas
enseigner le fait que le sionisme était
justement s'entêter à détruire le monde
arabe
c'est vrai que pour saddam tout le monde
le sait l'unité arabe était quand même
l'un à l'un des symboles de la réussite
du monde arabe en tout cas ils avaient
envie de construire justement l'unité
d'art l unité arabe et c'est vrai que
j'étais sous un régime totalitaire et
tout le monde sait qu sous un régime
totalitaire
la loi est celle de celui qui vous
gouvernent ont clairement on n'avait pas
le choix c'était les juifs étaient des
ennemis on était des enfants réciter par
coeur ce qu'on nous donnait ce qu'on
nous donnait à lire et à apprendre et
heureusement qu'à 14 ans je suis sorti
de ce pays c'est vraiment de la première
guerre du golfe pour 91 vous partez avec
votre mère vos frères
vous arrivez en france oui j'y arrive en
france à 14 ans j'ai quitté en tout cas
dans des circonstances très
particulières la guerre à falun l'irak
avec ma mère et mes deux petites soeurs
et et c'est vrai que bizarrement on nous
a appris à détester le juif mais c'est
vrai que jamais dans ma famille dans
laquelle j'ai été élevé on ne m'a jamais
dit en tout cas à la maison qu'il
fallait justement continuer à détester
les jus puis qu'il fallait tuer les
juifs etc
donc c'était vraiment dans les manuels
scolaires ça faisait partie de des
choses normales
voilà du programme scolaire